[موسيقى]
عشان كده هنضطر نرجع على البيت برجلينا
اوكي
هكذا بدات مسيره الدراسيه انا واخي محمد
نتقاسم بعد المسافات ومعورك الطريق يسجدنا
لطف الرحمن ودعوات امي
الحضور الكريم
بتتذكر شنو اول ما شوارب الدراسه في ناس
بتذكر صح المدرسه في ناس بتذكر معجبين في
ناس بتذكروا الاصدقاء والمعلمين وما الى
ذلك
بسه ومراجعه
المدرسه
مش موالين دراسي كنت عباره عن سعيد شجي
ابدا وشريره لاولادهم
[موسيقى]
عديت السنه الاولى عديت السنه الثانيه
السنه الثالثه في السنه الرابعه بين الكل
عباره
جاروس وكان بطل بذيء شديد
انه البيت وجع فقرر ينتقل لمنطقه خارج
البدايه
السنه ينقطع عن الدراسه
اشهر ثلاثه شهور وانا بعيد يعني بالدراسه
هون وانا كل يوم بتذكر صديقاتي ثلاث شهور
وانا كل يوم بيتذكر
وساحه المدرسه وسعيده زعلان عشان
[موسيقى]
حزينه جدا جدا
بعد ثلاث شهور رجعنا مره ثانيه
لكن المره دي رجعت سعيده للمقام الدراسه
سعيده غير الطفل الشقيه رجعت سعيد مسؤوله
نوعا الطعام سعيده امها انها تكون في
دراستها وبس
عده سنين جميله جدا جدا
بدات تشتغل كعامله في المنازل عشان اقدر
يا وطي مصاريف المدرسه عشان نقدر اوصف
[تصفيق]
الدراسه
واحتياجات درس العصر وغيره
وكانت مرحله جميله جدا محاطه
[موسيقى]
ومعلمات مميزات
عظيمه جدا جدا وكانت
[تصفيق]
الاساس الاولى على مستوى المدرسه وال
رابعه
دخلت بكل الفقره في الدنيا وبكل
التحيه يا
[موسيقى]
كل وتحققي اللي كان
الاسره مره ثانيه ينتقل لمنطقه في اطراف
منطقه اقل
[موسيقى]
انها بس ما كانت المشكله رامات كل الحاجات
اللي وراي لانه تحدي سنه ثالثه
شهاده يا انت لازم تحققي حلمك لازم تحققي
حلمك يا سعيده كل الحاجات دي ورانا
نزلت اقرب بالنسبه لي
هحكي
انه ما في كهرباء
ومع التغيبي من حصص التقويه ولاحق
اختلافهم عن صديقاتي اللي بيجوا يحكوا عن
امير الاساتذه والمجموعات
ولحقوا على معلمه الاحياء اللي كانت
بتعليق
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حلمي
85 بس بالنسبه لك
[تصفيق]
بسهوله
هتوديك وين هتمشي وين هتاخدي الشغل كيف
[موسيقى]
ممكن تعيدي اذا كان اللي باكله يعني من
وين هاي
من وين حضرتك انا
كل العبادي
الجامعه بكل انكسار
الحماس انطفى التحدي
غابه الاحلام
[موسيقى]
اربع سنين سعيده
خلصت سعيده وهكذا خلصت اربع سنين من غير
اي شرف من غير اي طموح من غير اي دخل
بعد سنين الجامعه
اشتغلنا في كثيره جدا
حكيتها قدر الميناء من الحاجات
لكن لسه جوايا احساس شديد للفشل احساس
شديد
[موسيقى]
احساس دواي بحطهم شديد احساس
بشعور بالذنب قادم انه انا باحلامي
واحلامي شعور الشديد احساس
بالرفق ما هي المجتمع وانما من نفسك وده
اصعب الدعاء احساس انك
تقبلها
احساس بايده انت مانك اي مكان في المجتمع
او انت ما بقدر اصلا
الرهيبه والناس ناجحه ابدا
بهذا الاحساس
لكن الاصعب انه
[موسيقى]
مزعجه جدا جدا بديت حتى اذا في الكلام
سعيد الكلام فصيحه جدا جدا واللي تعرف
بتدي من الطابور وبتجدي يعني
[موسيقى]
اخصائي
الاقي نفسي
اتصورت بحاله الفئه حد
ما مشكله العلاج العلاج
طويله جدا جدا سنين
[موسيقى]
من الحاجات
نصائح انه يا سعيده
التطوع وانت للاطفال في غسيل فشل الكلوي
فبمشي رجلين بمشي اتونس معاهم كنت بحس
بقيمه كنت بحس
بقيمه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاحتكاك بالمعلمين والطلب في البدايه
لاحظتها
من المعلم
في حاله اكتتاب المعلم في حاله جيم المعلم
نفسه في حاله
تقعد وتسمعني وبس
[موسيقى]
تعليم تقريبيه جدا جدا
في مهارات القرن الواحد والعشرين
في تدريب الصوره كويسه جدا بعدها جاب فكره
انه ليش مانع للطلب رسمهم نعمل لهم دورات
تدريبيه او ريش تدريبيه وفعلا بدانا نمشي
للطلبه في مكانه في مدارسه
[موسيقى]
صوره فعاله والعديد من المرعش الجميله جدا
واستفادوا منها بصوره كبيره جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
هل نحن نعقد نفسنا على الحاجات اللي خارج
او خارج ارادته
ما مفهوم نحن نتعامل مع نفسنا بغسل فعش
من التشوهات النفسيه اللي ممكن تحصل
لنا ممكن
ناخذ
من الاجاص
[موسيقى]
النقطه الاولى اطلع باداره الضحيه يا
اخوان الضحيه
على زووم وما الى ذلك فاطلع ضحيه
نجاحك او كشك بمسؤوليتك مسؤوليتك انت وبس
واذا كان
عشان تبدا
وتتفوق فهو
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ثانيا اعرف نفسك عشان تقدر تديره بشكل
كويس عرف نفسك اعرف روحك
انه انت عباره عن عقلي واعي وعقلي لا واعي
يمكن المعلومه جايه لما العيد خرجت كتير
في حياتي يعني لما انتم عارفينه انت عايش
عقلي واعي الحكم جدا جدا اللي هو انت قاعد
تحسب بتشاهد في سعيده وعقلي
وده بتحبك في حياتك
تديه له توجد واضح تدريبه واضحه تدي له
صوره واضحه للحامل
[موسيقى]
معناها
ابدا اتقبل نفسك زي ما الله خلق البالون
حاجه ربنا خلقه فيك تتجب لنا
[تصفيق]
قيم نفسك
واديها هدف وشغب تعيش عشاني
وكمان وصيه
ما تكبر مشاعرك سعر جواك
المشاعر السايبه في الرئه
بالاحساس
واللي في حياتنا يا اخي احكي لامك احكي
لامك احكي
خلاص انا بقى احكي
ايوه
كل الحالات الحاجات اللي وجعاكي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا كان ربنا
عشان نعلق مشان
هو في في طعم للنجاح من غير المنبشه
ده ونبدا من جديد
[موسيقى]
خطابه اصنع لنفسك دائره داخليه ايجابيه
نفسك بنفس ايجابيه ناس الحياه وناس
نفسها وتطويرها
حاجه ثانيه خطاب عايزه الغلام اعمل
بنفسك وبين مقدراتك وابدا
احط